[Musique]
moment cérémonial dans l'hémicycle du
département pour le concours défense et
illustration de la langue française
de nombreux thèmes d'actualité ont été
abordés par ces jeunes tels que
l'écologie ou encore le harcèlement
scolaire
soixante quatre lauréats sont
récompensés et fait exceptionnel 7 et
l'aide se sont distingués au concours
national dont deux premiers prix parce
que j'aime bien écrire est que ma prof
de français trouvent que j'écris bien et
elle pensé que ce serait bien de mettre
proposés ah oui ils sont très fiers
surtout ma mère parce que c'est celle
qui m'a initié à l'écriture et la
lecture c'était l'histoire d'une fille
qui est harcelé collège qui a beaucoup
de problèmes de famille elle va à cause
de tout ça elle va être amené à décider
mais en fait elle va quand elle va
sauter elle va se réveiller et découvrir
qu'elle était dans un coma elle va
retrouver toute sa famille est en fait
tout ce qu'elle a vécu c'était qu'un
mauvais rêve aussi vivre des aventures
sébacées pareil cd
voilà c'est surtout des aventures à
travers un livre c'est imaginer surtout
et voilà au fond de la salle les parents
sont tous prêts à ne pas manquer ces
récompenses qui font du bien à notre
jeunesse
ici peu importe les récompenses à
l'écrit n'existe plus un et c'est une
façon aussi également d'être détournée
de soi même les écrans en finit par
oublier tout ce qu'on peut avoir sur le
cas aurait elle donc elle là elles ont
vraiment exprimé vraiment leur leurs
émotions
notamment sur un thème on avait traité 1
harcèlement scolaire salaires
ça les avait vraiment touché un moment
important et plein de sens pour
l'association des membres de l'ordre de
la palme académique
ça sert à construire les styles de soi
ça serve à à savoir que la maîtrise de
la langue c'est un des outils de
l'excellence un des outils dont on va se
servir on construire son avenir et que
c'était extrêmement important entre
l'opération premières pages et
expositions dans les sites culturels
tels que l'année le compte de lille ou
encore les lieux d'expression de la
langue française comme la bibliothèque
départementale
la première bibliothèque de l'île la
collectivité accompagnent au quotidien
notre langue et c'est cet amour
finalement pour pour la connaissance
mais aussi pour l'imaginaire que les
bibliothèques véhicule encore elles sont
où ça reste l'état de l'établissement
culturel français le plus fréquenté
devant le cinéma à 30 français sur trois
vendu biotech
car tous les partenaires présents
s'accordent à dire que la défense de la
langue française est une nécessité et
surtout dans le cadre du développement
d'une india océanie
[Musique]